for the gun lobby members arriving at
their national convention there is
nothing odd or awkward about the timing
of this event
because there is they believe no
correlation between mass shootings and
guns
guns don't pick themselves up and kill
people it's people that do that he
managed to buy a gun
that's right legally
and walk into a school and shoot 19 kids
the school was negligent
he shouldn't had the doors open he
walked in an open door do you not think
the gun laws should be tightened
slightly no what they need to do is
enforce the ones they have they're not
doing their job they're letting those
people slip through the cracks
that's the issue you don't think the
issue is too many guns in america no
there are of course nuances some do want
regulation better policing but they all
want their guns can you give us a sense
of why it's important to you
we're a free country
inside guest of honor donald trump read
out the names of the children who died
mckenna
lee
elrod
[Music]
mai tai a mark of respect or deeply
distasteful the former president will
divide opinion as always sadly before
the sun
had even set on the horrible day of
tragedy we witnessed
a now familiar parade of cynical
politicians seeking to exploit the tears
of sobbing families
to increase their own power and take
away our constitutional rights but in
here they are at one the problem isn't
guns it's bad people
if we as a nation
were capable of legislating evil out of
the hearts and minds of criminals who
commit these heinous acts
we would have done it a long time ago
he wouldn't have seen the anti-gun
protests outside bigger and noisier than
even they expected
among them just listen to the views of a
17 year old student who says she is
scared in her classroom every day every
single person in that building right
there is complicit and they are helping
and something needs to be done just
why do you think they're complicit
because if you're not actively doing
something to help the problem you are
part of the problem the star guest here
is the democratic candidate for governor
one time presidential hopeful beto
o'rourke
mass shooting in this country
[Music]
they really do feel as though they have
an energy this time to bring about
meaningful change and however improbable
it may seem they think it could begin in
texas why do you think change will
happen this time we are committed to it
and we are going to act
we are going to break through right now
everyone here is committed to it
but against all this optimism is the
reality a divided ideology that feels
now to be so entrenched if nothing
changed when the country was less
divided how's it really possible now
mark stone sky news in houston